bb-bb-bb-bb-bb-bb-bb science alert
science alert alert
science science I mean dr. Lee yeah oh
well I we have a newfound I do i
something happened
what is this cover e-discovery oh god so
when I was five I used to eat little
tiny rocks in my fault long okay at home
well usually we used to live in Rancho
Bernardo you have Piko what do we Pike
Hika Hika is when you have like absurd
cravings for a weird type of food like
pregnant women if they had like a
vitamin deficiency they'll start eating
so it's like would [ __ ] I was alive I
was no pregnant [ __ ] I know maybe how
was I [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm a boy too [ __ ]
he's a mailman a bus oh I see Little
Rock's okay and they were specific
looking I just remember them distinctly
as a kid they were like they you know
why a dumb because they were a little
tiny they're tiny and they they I like
cereal and look it's it's like serious
now he find out how he actually the
origin story listen up everywhere so the
other day I was in the bath and I was
feeling something around my anus oh this
is the other day I remember there's an
event
yeah I yell Eureka it was like Eureka I
say Eureka Eureka so I pick I pick out a
little pebble from my anus get down here
and I look at it and it looks just like
the little tiny [ __ ] rocks I used to
eat when I was five
whoa listen so I'm like there's no way
there's no [ __ ] way yes yeah but then
I smelled it okay no just listen okay
you it's melted
it's melded like that should be a word
by the way
yeah smell smells out the smell this it
smells that he likes it
beyond [ __ ] oh it was beyond
how do you know it was a level of it you
know you know what [ __ ] smells like
we'll give you some yeah like why don't
I can't describe it Oh mommy deep Bobby
did I write primeval primeval okay I'm
evil try me right it was close but there
was an undercurrent of something else
foul at play here like corpse like dead
[ __ ]
Oh God so when I smelled it I did one of
those face things you know that Bojo
does when he spoke in sass yeah I did
one of those and I stuck the rock on the
side of that little panel there on the
bathtub and I just started bathing
myself I was gonna let it go because I
was gonna throw it away later looking at
it I go exactly and I smelled it again
the same don't stop smell its name
reaction right this is what I did then
then I put shampoo right and soap and
that I had that santel 33 so I started
watching it's very more that you shall
act at your nose in the rock the rock
you shall and I would started washing it
handing for gold
yeah very gaining for the Roger you're
being intuitive yeah yeah so I was
smelling it after I washed it deeply it
was even worse it did the [ __ ] Chanel
was at the core of this little rock and
then I realized that this has been said
my body since I was five you think so
yeah holy [ __ ]
that'd be fermenting inside my colon
right for [ __ ] 40 40 years how did it
get past the hydrochloric acid in your
stomach maybe he's bi let me out I don't
know what you just said I don't tell you
this right now I thought this is a
science moment you should know what HCl
is this that's
very good that you said that thank you
for mentioning thank you for watching
I'll tell you why
all right because this rock was a little
smaller than the rocks I used to eat so
the Holika lauric right I think it
brought it down to a smaller size Oh II
wrote it it was eroded erosion so it was
initially much bigger yes but that's
it's science and you know I liked it
I've test what I wanted to open this
podcast with you me something that's
just two things can live inside your
body is that true now you being a nurse
I don't being a nurse and I used to know
what comes I your ass forty years no
what I'm saying is is that like I
remember doing a colonic thing you know
when they used to do with the machine
where you can see the - yeah the
colonics right so the bad yes yeah I did
it a couple of times oh wow and you
would you know I mean you would like
look right at this little tube and
things would go you could see through it
things that were inside you yeah you'd
see a fingernail right a ring you know I
mean like Bobbie rings I don't know I
you know things were in a lottery ticket
you know you would say so maybe and I
remember the ladies saying that you know
things stay inside you they'd get
trapped in there like a prisoner I read
the prisoner in hell someone in an
asparagus and the tip of the asparagus
came out of their butt or they just fell
out what like the whole asparagus no
just the tip from how long was it in
there it was like a day forty years in
the making
that means he doesn't chew his food no
it's just that proves that it proves
that it went through no but yeah of
course some things can go through if you
don't have proper absorption if you have
either like your small intestines not
absorbing it correctly your colons not
absorbing the final yeah if your
stomach's not breaking it down correctly
like a lot of people with like IBD and
stuff it goes right through them they
put they eat they [ __ ] like let me ask
you something in the stomach or their
side Caverns
if you have diverticulitis no I'm not
talking normal stomachs like if I eat
something
and the food is traveling to whatever
the party tubes look for sure
party party party tubes you can for sure
have a lot of like caked in like
petrified stuff over time there we go
yes what I'm saying it's probably
unlikely it is the same rock that you
hate is it impossible I mean I am a
personal at 40 years from now is when
you discover the same Rock I think it
would have passed three especially since
and that's why you don't believe in
miracles I don't believe in that time
yeah that dreamer and I don't you know
that's that that's a that's not good
yeah you gotta be a dreamer how about
you George you believe be real be honest
with me I want honest you know come on
man
whoa he's about to use hongki's how
about you man you know what what I
believe cuz some [ __ ] has gone to my
door
can I just say this to you my friend I
really I'm not even drunk I'm not okay
either I'm gonna the possibility in the
way you said it with your favor and I
when we die we're gonna be in a special
place in heaven okay
Elvin yeah you and I are gonna be with
cool people
patro yes right yes the guy that
invented um sparkling water the guy from
Leeds England from Leeds England oh he's
great yeah I remember his name Jeremy
Piven not Jeremy he's not gonna be in
our little circle don't he we got you
don't
yeah you know what it's so funny when
you're done you go to heaven though if
you think about this is is that everyone
that died before you was up there that's
good right so we get to hang out with
some cool people up there all right what
age are they like it's Charles Mann oh
wait no he's do you stay the same age or
do you get to choose what point of your
life will meet the first guy that ever
had a fleet foot oh my god George it can
you put the AC on the Commission's you
mean like I'll be like on a cloud and
some like white dude will walk by and
I'd be like hey are you the one first
guy that ever get athlete's foot
the guy was made heard why would he be
in heaven because he was the first like
he maybe you ran a lot I don't know Oh
[Music]